There’s a non-foregone phenomenon in any prosperous nation
When primal fears all disappear the brain then gets a sensation
The medical name we gave this pain is affluenflammation
Honey, these scientists are saying we shouldn't vaccinate the kids.
Ol’ Bill Tub is chugging a jug of cold bovine lactation
When his eyes then realize that carton side’s got information
And since his life contains no strife it’s affluenflammation
As millions starve across-
-are saved thanks to a new drought resistant-
-smallpox has taken another-
-make sure to bundle up out there, because it's polio season.
For the better part of history diseases all were raging
Measles, mumps up on your junk like they were Kevin Spacey
Then came Jonas Salk
First ever polio vaccine.
Makes you wonder what all for…
Cuz we’ve got affluenflammation
I'll just put some peppermint oil on it.
We’ve got affluenflammation
Prioritize profit and the accumulation of money above all else
and we seek it at any human and environmental cost.
Ol’ Chip Black is cracking the back of twelve live-steamed crustaceans
For the perks and glee of living free he starts to lose appreciation
And if you probe his frontal lobe—yep—affluenflammation
Everyone's still starving-
-starving still-
-starving with a chance of flurries.
Still starving here in the country.
Starving, wait, what changed?
Through the course of human history each day we faced starvation
Rats and pox and chamber pots, streets filled with defecation
Free markets changed the norm
Makes you wonder what all for…
Cuz we’ve got affluenflammation
I really need work.
We’ve got affluenflammation
Take your jobs elsewhere Amazon!
And that's how you run the global economy.
We’ve got affluenflammation